DON DODGE: Hello everyone.
My name's Don Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today my guest is Jennifer
Reuting,
founder and CEO of DocRun.
Jennifer is a serial
entrepreneur.
She's started several companies
and today we'll talk
a little bit about
how that went.
Welcome, Jennifer.
JENNIFER REUTING: Hi.
DON DODGE: All right.
So you started InCorp and
MyLLC, and your current
company, DocRun.
JENNIFER REUTING: Correct.
DON DODGE: So when did you
start your first company?
JENNIFER REUTING: I started
my first company at 17.
I started college early, so I
was in college at the time,
and a typical college dropout.
I did end up going back for
a time to get my degree.
But yeah, pretty early.
DON DODGE: 17 years old you
started your first company.
Wow.
So what experience did
you have before you
started that company?
You couldn't have had much.
You were barely out
of high school.
JENNIFER REUTING: No.
Yeah, I had no experience.
And actually I don't think that
I would have started the
company had I had the experience
that I have now,
because the market that I was
penetrating was actually
really evolved at the time.
It registered agent company
and corporate compliance.
And our two largest competitors
are both public
companies at this point.
So it was super-saturated
and I just had no
idea what I was doing.
So all I knew was that I wanted
to create value and
just see those checks
rolling in.
It was just about the number of
customers that we could get
at that point.
It was such a single-minded
focus.
DON DODGE: So you're
17 years old.
You don't have any
entrepreneurialship
experience, probably haven't
worked that many jobs.
How did you decide to
do incorporations
or registered agent?
At 17, I didn't even know
such a thing existed.
JENNIFER REUTING: I actually
fell into it.
I don't think that when you
aren't setting out to be an
entrepreneur, you just sort
of fall into things.
And I was working for these
investment bankers.
I was really tired of working
for people, frankly.
DON DODGE: At 17.
JENNIFER REUTING: That
was driving me.
Yeah.
I actually had just gotten fired
by a retail job for a
stupid reason.
It was the stupidest reason.
It defied all logic for me.
And I was like, I'm never
working for anybody again.
And then I ended up getting
a job for these investment
bankers as a secretary.
And what we were doing
at the time was
taking companies public.
And involved in that is forming
the companies, and we
were also the registered agent
for the companies.
And one day I come into
the office and the
place had been ransacked.
And my bosses had fled
the country.
Yeah, one went to Mexico.
The other one went
to Switzerland.
And all the other employees were
like, well, I guess we're
out of a job, right?
And I knew and I told them that
we paid the office rent
for the rest of the
year, because we
paid it all up front.
And so I was like, well, we
have to do something.
And nobody else was game,
so it was just me.
And I was like, I can't
take companies public.
That involves a whole
slew of people.
But I was accepting the
service of process.
As a registered agent,
that's what you do.
It's really easy.
Basically, you accept mail
and you forward it.
And we charge companies
$200 a year for that.
And I'm like, well,
that's easy.
I can do that.
Anybody can do that.
And I'll you need
is an office.
And so I started mailing
to companies--
because it was public
information, Secretary of
State database--
basically offering them
a free year of
registered agent service.
And I'm like, if I can
just get through one
year I'll be golden.
Because in my 17-year-old brain
I was like, if I can
charge $200 a year, and if I get
1,000 companies, I'm like,
that $200,000 a year.
I'm going to be rich!
And so I just started mailing,
and people started responding.
And then I started getting
my scholarship
checks in the mail.
And I was like, well, I could
use it for postage or I could
sit through a lot of
math courses that I
didn't want to take.
And that was the genesis
of InCorp.
And now we have over 60
employees, and we're set to do
well over $20 million
this year.
DON DODGE: So you started InCorp
at 17 years old and it
still exists today.
JENNIFER REUTING: Yeah.
DON DODGE: Wow.
That's amazing.
So most entrepreneurs that I
talk to, they get a passion
about some thing or they want to
improve something or change
the world and they go
and start a company.
Your story is a little
different.
You found an opportunity, you
had a year or free office
space, and you knew
a few things and
said, why not do this.
Did you get passionate
about incorporations?
And where did you find your
drive to build this business
and make it big?
JENNIFER REUTING: My parents
didn't have a lot of money.
They were always having
money problems.
And I didn't have the
easiest childhood.
It wasn't hard.
It wasn't like anything
terrible.
I know my mom's probably
watching this.
Got to be careful there,
otherwise I'll be getting a
phone call.
But I think that some people are
running towards things and
other people are running
away from things.
And I think at that time it
was just really, nobody
believed in me.
I remember I wanted money for
school, for school books.
And one of my relatives was
like, well, you're not going
to graduate anyway.
And they would say things
like that and it
would just drive me.
I'm like, well, screw you.
I can do it.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to be independent.
I'm going to accomplish
something.
And then it just kind of became
a little bit of--
I found just one key metric that
I got fulfillment out of,
which was the number of
customers that we got.
Because the number of customers
that we got was
really my shining thing where,
in the future, this is going
to be what's going
to sustain me.
And so people may not understand
what I'm doing now.
And I'm sleeping in a sleeping
bag on the floor of the office
because I'm broke.
But I know that as that number
rose, I knew that that was
like, hey, I'm going
to be balling.
I'm going to be somebody, and
I'm going to actually prove
them wrong.
And then after a while, you
get used to the success.
And that's when, for me, it was
the thing that drove me
became more vision and wanting
to make a mark on the world.
But it definitely wasn't
the catalyst.
I think the catalyst more just
proving people wrong.
I was a nutty 17-year-old.
DON DODGE: Well, you've
certainly proven people wrong.
You've now started
three companies.
The latest one, DocRun, tell me
a little bit about DocRun.
What do you do there?
JENNIFER REUTING: So DocRun
actually, the idea for it came
out of the other companies,
because one of my other
companies is a formation company
and we do a lot with
small businesses.
And so I interact a lot with
some small businesses and
entrepreneurs in even writing
LLCs for dummies, I've
interacted a lot with that
world and gotten
passionate about it.
And the one thing that's just
become so clear to me is that
people form their businesses.
It's really easy.
You can go on a number of
websites, pay $100 or so, and
you get your documents mail.
But they have no concept of what
to do after that point.
They don't know how to bring
on partners, or they don't
know what happens if two of the
partners want to kick out
another partner, or how to hire
employees and do it legally.
And what I was also finding
was that a lot of the
entrepreneurs aren't typically
what we experience in the tech
world, people that
are going out and
getting funded, et cetera.
It's the people that are getting
laid off and maybe
have $10,000 in their savings
account to start a business,
because they really
don't have any
alternative other than welfare.
But that's the beauty
of America.
Right?
We're very entrepreneurial.
So they can't afford the
heavy legal fees
that lawyers charge.
And so what I decided with
DocRun was that I wanted to
create a software solution
that really took out the
drafting of the contracts and
agreements away from lawyers
to be able to make it affordable
for people.
In that way, they can access
lawyers for just the
high-level stuff, for the
guidance, for the stuff that
they're really therefore.
Right?
And that's where all the
value is provided.
So we're breaking down that
barrier to entry for small
businesses, to really
be able to embrace
the law and be legit.
And business owners can sleep
at night knowing that they
have partnership agreements.
You'd be surprised how many
partnerships have no contracts
between the partners.
DON DODGE: So DocRun provides
legal documents for small
businesses, employment
agreements.
What kinds of things
are involved?
JENNIFER REUTING: So really,
it's partnership agreements,
bylaws, all the formalities
if you have a corporation,
employment contracts, offer
letters, stock option plans--
if you want to venture into that
for your business that's
now accessible for average
entrepreneurs--
profit sharing plans,
termination letters,
everything from terms of use
for your website, privacy
policies, anything relating
bringing on partners or
removing partners, and selling
shares for investment, raising
capital, or even dissolving
your business.
DON DODGE: So you found a
problem of forming companies
and having these agreements.
They were very, very
expensive.
And you thought you could do
it for less money and save
people money and make money
in the same time.
What did you know about this?
Or is it, once again,
it didn't matter.
You could just figure
it out and do it?
JENNIFER REUTING: Well, when I
was writing the first edition
of LLCs for Dummies, I knew
operating agreements are very
crucial for a limited
liability company.
In some states, you're not even
valid if you don't have
an operating agreement
in place.
In other states, if you don't
have a specific provision in
your operating agreement,
it's not even valid.
And so some of these
solutions, the
fill-in-the-blank forms
you get aren't really
state-specific.
And so when I was writing the
book, I just decided here's
how to do it.
I'm going to show you a broad
thing, but really
just go to a lawyer.
And after the book was
published, I get about 4 to 5
Ask Jennifer questions
a day on the site.
And I just got a
huge blowback.
So people were saying,
I can't afford it.
They wanted a $5,000 retainer,
or just an astronomical fee.
And what's another solution?
And they just kept
asking me that.
And so when I wrote the second
edition I'm like, I'm not
making that mistake again.
I went to a lot of attorneys,
and I was asking them, these
are my friends.
I'm like, maybe we can do
something that's at a price
point that people can afford.
And they just weren't willing or
able to do it because they
have their own school
loans to pay off.
And it just wasn't really
offering a viable profit
margin for them.
And so at that point I was
like, well, I have
to write this book.
I have to put something
in there.
I'm not going to subject myself
to another two years of
complaints by readers.
So I went and purchased a domain
name called DocRun.
And in the book I was like,
just go to DocRun.
And I had no idea what I was
going to do or how I
was going to do it.
And I like, well, I have
some time before--
I just had to create
something.
So I had to figure it out.
DON DODGE: So you created the
need for DocRun by writing the
book, and then you had
to scramble to--
JENNIFER REUTING: Figure out
what the solution was.
Yeah.
And really, when you look at
what an attorney does and how
he create contracts, it's
something that's really akin
to being automated
with software.
DON DODGE: You're obviously
a woman.
JENNIFER REUTING: I hope so.
DON DODGE: And three-time
entrepreneur.
Are there special challenges
for a woman entrepreneur
starting a company?
JENNIFER REUTING: Not in tech.
When I started InCorp, I
ended up bringing on a
partner who is a man.
And half the time--
And he was just really doing
all the programing.
I was running the business.
And he would even come to me
and get quite clearly upset
that people just wouldn't
talk to me.
They wouldn't engage with me.
And I think that after so many
years of that, in that sort of
world, the corporate world
where women especially--
I was so young.
I had a lie about my age to
everybody, even the employees.
My birthday parties, there was
like, always 16 every year.
I'm sure people started
wondering.
I think that was difficult.
It sort of put me on guard, to
the point where it sort of fed
into that, well, nobody believes
in you anyway, that
sort of thing.
And it's been really fascinating
to me migrating
over to the tech industry.
It embraces women and
embraces youth.
And had I known this before, I
just would have started in the
tech industry, because I
would have been golden.
I never would've thought that
anybody would ever invest in
me, even when my company was
successful, because I was
young and I was a woman,
back then.
And I just had no idea that
there was this amazing
industry that's just so
embracing of people that don't
necessarily fit the norm.
And I think that it's
interesting to me, a lot of
VCs, if they do feel reluctant
to invest in a female founder,
especially a single founder like
myself, I can understand
it to some extent, because
there aren't any really
successful female
single founders.
I have my own theories on why
that is, but it hasn't
bothered me.
We have plenty of funding and
plenty of people that believe
in me and want to fund
and back me.
So it's fine.
There hasn't been any
big issues there.
And hopefully, I can pave that
way and be one of the people.
That's something that's really,
personally driving me.
DON DODGE: So Jennifer, you're
breaking all the rules.
You're young, a woman,
a sole founder.
Most of the time, we want
multiple founders.
And you've raised money
and been successful.
So tell me about how it went,
raising money and starting a
tech company.
JENNIFER REUTING: Oh, it was
definitely hard because I'm a
sole founder.
But I wanted to be.
I'm a little bit--
It kind of pissed me off that
people would say, oh, we only
invest in teams or, oh, where's
the technical component.
I think that at the time, I
was very there are no sole
female founders.
But we're good at
business too.
So I actually was pretty
adamant about
being a sole founder.
And that was interesting.
It definitely was interesting.
I had to learn how to pitch.
I'm not good at asking
for anything.
I'm very, very--
I can do things myself.
I'm actually good at asking for
advice, because to me when
you ask somebody for advice
it's a complement to them.
So really, it's an
equal exchange.
I don't know.
But the idea of going out and
asking for capital, Ive never
raised capital before.
And I was always so proud of
never taking on any debt with
my company, never raising
any capital.
I was just proud of
bootstrapping.
But this needed to be the next
chapter in my evolution as an
entrepreneur.
And embracing that was
something I needed.
It was a personal journey for
me that I had to take.
And learning how to use
PowerPoint, oh my gosh.
I hate PowerPoint.
If I could raise capital
without pitching on a
PowerPoint, that
would be ideal.
DON DODGE: Maybe that's
your next company.
JENNIFER REUTING: Yeah.
There you go.
I'm still not into the
PowerPoint thing.
I'll have to get better
at that, for sure.
DON DODGE: So you seem
to like challenges.
And that seems to motivate
what you do.
So my question is what
does motivate you?
JENNIFER REUTING: You
know, it's funny.
The seed of the idea and really
the overall passion for
wanting to just disrupt this
industry and to make it so
that people own the law.
Lawyers have charged this
premium for knowledge.
And people haven't really
had access to it.
And they feel this dissociation
with it, when in
reality people own the law.
It's for us to use and to
protect ourselves with.
And so that's the overarching
thing that drives me.
But I think also on a day-to-day
basis is looking at
my team, the people that have
taken these ridiculous pay
cuts to come work for me, and
investors, and it's just
knowing that I don't want to
let those people down.
So on a day-to-day basis, it's
really just, I can't let these
people down.
They believed in me.
I will die before I fail you.
And I want to make the
journey worth it.
I want them to be like, that
was an amazing journey.
And we had bumps in the road,
and there were times, and
there were great times.
And at of the day, the success
and feeling the mutual
success, and I want to
give that to them.
DON DODGE: What about the
other side of that?
What about when the employees
let you down and you have to--
Have you ever had
to fire someone?
JENNIFER REUTING: Oh yeah.
Recently.
It was tough.
It was really tough.
It's not just about firing
somebody for poor performance.
I recently had to let somebody
go because he was an
executive, because there was
just a disparity in the
vision, in the core value
of what I'm trying to
accomplish at DocRun.
And when this person's running
over half of your team and
interacting with them on a
day-to-day basis and just sort
of circumventing the vision
you're trying to bring people
in on, I had to let
that person go.
And the problem was is that he
was a great employee, and he
was passionate.
So there was really
nothing wrong.
And he'd sacrificed a lot.
But it just was one of those
things where there can only
really be one vision.
And when there's something
that's completely conflicting,
especially lawyers--
that's the difficulty of having
a company that's trying
to disrupt the legal industry,
and it's full of lawyers--
you have to keep very close
guard that we're on the same
page, that we're not slipping
into that legal sort of
mindset of making this a
product for lawyers.
Or we don't want to dumb down
our consumers or to dumb down
our demographic.
Yes.
The answer is yes.
DON DODGE: So how do you keep
that vision and passion and
everyone on the same page?
Are there things that
you do every day
to make that stronger?
Or is it just a natural
leadership kind of thing?
JENNIFER REUTING: I was almost
doing it too much, to the
point where there was a little
bit of backlash.
People were like, OK, we need
to stop having all of these
meetings where we're talking
about vision.
So I think that I've pretty
indoctrinated everybody.
We know where we're heading.
And now, vision needs to
permeate everything.
Right?
So in your conversations, when
I'm talking to employees about
certain things--
Like even just today I was
talking to somebody about the
tone of our help content, just
helping people, guiding them
through the process, and what
the tone should be.
And having a clear vision,
saying, OK well, we want to
empower people so we're not
going to talk down to them,
but we still want to
be approachable.
It sort of permeates every
aspect of your business.
And to me, one of things I'm
working on right now that I
feel like a lot of entrepreneurs
don't spend
enough time on is their brand.
Because the brand is the
vision incarnate.
It's the representation of the
vision, visually, and just how
you present yourself
to the user.
And so just in the same way that
a brand permeates your
marketing, in all aspects
of your marketing
it needs to be cohesive.
I think your vision needs to
permeate your communication
with your team, and just
making sure that you're
consistent, that you're not
deviating from it, and
checking yourself to make sure
that you're not being a
heat-seeking missile and getting
excited by something
that's not really part
of the core vision.
DON DODGE: So DocRun
competes with some
pretty significant companies.
Legal Zoom is a competitor and
there might be others.
They advertise on television,
so you're up against some
pretty big competitors.
How do you work on the brand and
the vision to break out so
people know who you are?
JENNIFER REUTING: Well, the
irony is that these
competitors like Legal Zoom
don't actually do what we do.
But that doesn't necessarily
make them not a competitor,
because their brand is so
all-encompassing and is just
out there so much that people
generally tend to associate it
with anything that has to do
with business and the law,
especially the name,
Legal Zoom.
So that's been a challenge.
It drives me nuts every time I
say what we do, they're like,
oh, like Legal Zoom.
I'm like, they don't do that!
We're really picking where those
companies like Legal
Zoom, even my company, left off,
essentially, after the
formation process.
So there are some competitors,
but one of the things that
we're actually doing
is we're just--
The vision is very different
for where we're headed.
We're making the system
task based.
We're really trying to take the
information that our users
give us during the Q&A and just
tailor the environment to
their individual situation.
Because so much of what's in
the industry right now is
trying to shove people into this
one-size-fits-all thing,
whether it be form documents
or something just like some
general Q&A that fills in
the blanks for you.
And it's inherently broken.
It's not really even
legally viable.
And it's a little dangerous.
So in order for us to evolve,
the system that we've created
we're looking at it from the
opposite perspective, where
we're actually looking at how
we can organically replicate
the attorney process of creating
a document, rather
than looking at it from
how can we make forms
easier to fill out.
Hopefully our product will
speak for itself.
There will be a price
differentiation there for
sure, which will also
cue people that this
is something better.
In our user testing sessions,
people are given.
I mean, the average price just
for an operating agreement,
that they're saying they would
pay is about $400 to $500.
That's been very promising,
because we're probably not
even a start--
So when they interact with the
product, they really are
looking at it as something
that is akin to
maybe using a lawyer.
And hopefully we can have
lawyers pick up
where we leave off.
DON DODGE: Excellent.
So you started your first
company at 17.
This is your third company, and
you're still very young.
Where do you see things
going 5 years from
now, 10 years now?
Do you have grander visions or
do you always have your eye on
the ball, the thing that's
right in front of you?
JENNIFER REUTING: I think that
one of the things that women
don't do enough is plan their
lives, as So for me, I do want
to have a family
at some point.
But I'm not going to delude
myself to think that I can do
it while starting a business.
So probably after this, I might
do that for a few years.
And then I'll do another
venture.
I'm not a serial entrepreneur,
ironically.
I'm not the type that I'm like,
OK, this business is
done, what's the next
thing I can start.
I have to be just grabbed by
something so much that I
can't not do it.
So it's pretty variable.
I don't know if after I do this
business and we have an
exit I instantly have that
moment where I can't not do it
with something else.
Or if I don't then, you have to
see where things take you.
I think it's hard to plan
bursts of inspiration.
DON DODGE: I think you hit
it right on the head.
It's that you have to have
passion for the idea, and you
can't think about
anything else.
I have entrepreneurs come to
me or people with ideas and
they say, I have three or four
ideas for companies, and I
don't know which one to do.
And my answer to them is,
don't do any of them.
Because if there isn't
one idea that is just
all-consuming and you can't
think about anything else then
don't do it.
JENNIFER REUTING: I know.
I feel so lucky when I compare
myself to other entrepreneurs.
We pretty much have product
markets fit.
We're pretty I know exactly what
it is that I want to do.
It's pretty clear.
And any pivoting that's going to
be going on are going to be
maybe like pricing or how we
deliver the product, smaller
things within the vision.
And I just feel really bad for
entrepreneurs that don't have
that and are wavering between
things, and they don't
necessarily know what it
is that they want.
And I think that the danger is,
yes, you let user testing
drive your iterations, but it
should be within the confines
of a very clear vision.
But when you let user testing
drive your vision and you let
metrics drive your vision,
I just, don't know.
I feel bad for people that are
always having to pivot and
they don't necessarily
know what it is that
they want to do.
DON DODGE: So you're driven by
a vision, and you have a
direction, and nothing's
going to stop you?
JENNIFER REUTING: Yeah.
Some of our investors
hate that, for sure.
Because I'm like, no,
we're doing it.
But yeah, I just know.
But that's the luxury
of spending
your time in one market.
I have 10 years experience in
this market and with this
demographic.
And I am so well aware of how to
approach them, how to sell
them, I have sales channels
already established.
The benefit of just
understanding your demographic
and also just being a subject
matter expert on what you're
doing, it's understandable
why investors like that.
Because it just gives you a
confidence and a knowledge
that you can build your vision
off of, so you're
not going in blind.
DON DODGE: I want to ask you
about special challenges or
differences in being a woman
entrepreneur versus a man.
Have you found anything that
has been different or
challenging or just different?
JENNIFER REUTING: Pretty much
every week or so I get asked
to be on a panel about
women entrepreneurs.
I go to a lot of these things.
I get dragged to a
lot of things.
And a lot of women tend
to focus too much
on that, in my opinion.
I'm not a woman entrepreneur.
I'm an entrepreneur.
To me, they're very separate.
I think that women tend to feel
that in order to compete
they have to be masculine.
and they have to be something
that they're not.
They have to be sort of
inauthentic when they're at
the office, or put on a face.
And I've never--
No, that's a lie.
I have felt that.
I felt a lot when I
was with InCorp.
But I think that over the years
I've just become really,
really comfortable
with myself.
And I don't see myself as--
My team follows me because
I do cools things.
I'm smart, and I come up with
good ideas, and I engage them,
and I'm passionate.
And that allows me to be a
little bit silly and just the
kind of girl.
I don't feel the need to cut
my hair short and to be all
over-dominating and domineering
at the office.
And also, I think that I'm
starting to embrace the
qualities of being a woman.
I think that there's a lot of
qualities that women have that
we need to embrace more,
which is we're very
intuitive by nature.
And I think they just we're
very compassionate.
And so in my conversations--
and I've watch myself evolve
over time as an entrepreneur
and as I become more comfortable
with myself.
It's just a part
of growing too.
But now in my conversations,
when I fire people, I don't
have that guard up
that I used to.
I can be this compassionate
woman.
I actually fired somebody
recently and it was a really
sad conversation. and I took him
to coffee went and I was
talking about his business
and I put my arm around.
I was like, let me help you.
I think this isn't the
right path for you.
But it was just having that
sort of compassionate
understanding and.
Just embracing the good
qualities that we have.
DON DODGE: Do you think that
compassion and intuitive
nature helps in other parts
of the business
and building a company?
JENNIFER REUTING: Well, yeah.
I think that emotional
intelligence is huge, right?
It's funny.
I'm super getting into
poker lately.
I'm just killing it
lately at poker.
It seems like there's this tie
between my business and my
poker game.
And to me, it's sort of a
metaphor for business.
It's not so much about the cards
that you're dealt, it's
your intuitive understanding
of what's happening at the
table, your intuitive
understanding of all the
pieces, and all the components,
and the other players.
And I think that having that
sort of compassion and
intuition, it also helps
with building culture.
Because you can sort
of tap in.
When things aren't right,
you know it.
If things aren't right at your
company and the culture's off,
even if people--
As a CEO, people tend to hide
a lot of stuff from you.
They do.
And they put on the happy face
and they'll say, oh,
everything's great.
But it's like poker.
They put on their poker faces.
And then you have to sort of
feel, OK, there's something
that's not right here.
What's really going on?
Let's get to the root of this.
So I think it helps with
company culture.
I think it helps with
in negotiations.
If you are a naturally
empathetic person and
compassionate person, I never
have a problem negotiating.
Because to me, it's a
win-win situation.
If it was anything but a win-win
situation, I wouldn't
be happy with myself.
So by tapping into what is
beneficial for the other
person involved in the
arrangement and getting a feel
for what their needs are,
that's kind of what
compassion--
Yeah.
So I think that ultimately
that's pretty beneficial.
DON DODGE: So you've certainly
been a successful
entrepreneur.
This is your third company.
Why do you think there aren't
more women entrepreneurs?
JENNIFER REUTING:
I think that--
and this isn't universal.
All this stuff, it's pretty
controversial because people
tend to say like, oh,
I'm not like that,
and so it's all wrong.
But honestly, I believe that
it has to do with limiting
beliefs about yourself.
I feel really lucky that I grew
up with a dad and around
brothers and I was never
treated like a girl.
I was kind of tomboy.
And I never had any
limiting beliefs.
But when you're a girl
in a typical
family, you're coddled.
Right?
You have a 16-year-old son,
you're going to let him stay
out past midnight.
You have a 16-year-old
girl, you'd better
call me as soon as--
Who are you out with?
And so when you treat girls
differently in that way it's
natural, because we want
to protect women.
That's how society is.
But it causes some limiting
beliefs seen.
I'm sure that has some
psychological effect.
Well, am I not as capable?
Am I more of a victim
in this world?
And that sort of permeates
throughout life unless they're
able to sort of address it
and say, OK, that doesn't
necessarily apply to business.
I think it's also
facing fears.
I feel like women have to
actively get over some of
those limiting beliefs.
A lot of women that I know want
to start businesses, they
want to do small things.
They want to be independent
contractors.
They want to do, I want
to have a publicity
firm and be a publicist.
Or things that really involve
their own merits, as opposed
to, I want to disrupt that
space and be the market
leader, and I'm not going to
stop until I get there.
And I don't hear that
a lot from women.
I hear that more from men.
And I think that whatever's
holding women back from
feeling that they're able to
accomplish that and they're
able to go out and do a big, big
things, is probably where
we need to start.
DON DODGE: Have you found that
your first company gave you
confidence and your second
company gave you more
confidence and the third one?
Did that build on itself?
I have a sense that you were
pretty confident right from
the get-go, right
from the first--
JENNIFER REUTING: No.
I was fake confident.
I was really fake confident.
And I'm fake confident
all the time.
Ultimately, you just have
to fake it until
you make it, right?
Facing fears is a big deal.
So I try to do things that
challenge myself.
I have to be out of my comfort
zone as often as possible.
And I think that's the quality
over so many years that's a
really given me a self
confidence and just this
self-assuredness.
I know that no matter what
I'm going to be OK.
Because I have travelled to
Russia and I was there by
myself in crazy situations on
trains with Russian police.
And I got out of that one,
so this is nothing.
So travelling by myself a lot
and just taking adventures,
and basically anything that I'm
afraid of, just biting the
bullet and doing it.
Like I'm going to do jump out
of an airplane here in the
next couple weeks.
And I was just like, I'm
just booking it.
I'm not going to
think about it.
I'm just going to do it.
Because you just got to get
it out of your system.
You can't have things
holding you back.
And doing that continuously over
years all of the sudden
your comfort zone just keeps
getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger.
And as you fail and then as you
overcome failing and have
a good cry over it--
there's been some pretty
massive, horrible failures
from this fear from that
sort of mindset.
I get myself into
some situations
that are just terrible.
But then you come out of it,
and you're like, those are
always the best stories.
And then you know that
no matter what--
I was actually talking to
somebody about this the other
day, and it was actually in
relation to travelling by
myself and just doing
crazy adventures--
I was like, sometimes things
don't work out and things are
really shitty.
And it's like that
in business too--
actually, it's really like
this in business also--
and are really shitty and you
make a terrible mistake or
just a situation sucks, those
are always the stories.
Those are the stories that
you're talking about when
you're at dinner with friends
and when you're like, yeah,
you wouldn't believe when
this happened to me.
And so when I'm ever in the
middle of a shitty situation,
that's always going through my
mind that this is going to be
a good story.
And it puts things in
perspective that
this is just temporary.
This isn't like the
world is ending.
This is going to be a really
good story one day.
DON DODGE: Well, you learn a lot
more from failure than you
do from success.
So if you can keep failure in
that frame of mind, that it's
really a learning experience,
and a month from now you'll be
smarter for it and you'll have
forgotten all the pain, then I
guess that helps.
JENNIFER REUTING: It was
actually a big thing too, a
journey I had to take, was being
able to separate success
from self worth.
Because I think that when your
value as a human beings starts
to depend on your success then
all of the sudden failure
takes on a whole new meaning.
And then you become
afraid of failure.
So I think that people that are
too wrapped up in success,
that's sort of who they are and
that's their identity, it
actually hinders.
And I'm speaking from
experience, because I went
through a phase where I was
like, if I wasn't a
successful, who am I.
And I had to really learn how to
separate those two in order
to be able to fail.
It's kind of funny.
And in order to be able to fail,
I could actually be more
successful.
So to get to the next level of
success, I had to make success
mean less and learn how
to fail better.
DON DODGE: Amazing.
Do you have any people that you
look up to or are inspired
by or that you ask advice for?
Or are you pretty much on your
own and do your own thing?
JENNIFER REUTING: Yes.
I have people everywhere,
actually.
I probably talk to a mentor in
one form or another a couple
times a week.
Right now, I have a mentor
that's a CIO at a pretty big
company that's just been really
amazing, helping me
with some tech challenges
that I'm having.
And at the end of the day,
limiting yourself to your own
knowledge it's just like such
a losing proposition.
Because there's just no way to
compete with somebody who has
access to other people's
knowledge in different
industries, to the point where
if you have enough mentorship
I think you can probably
even do anything.
I think that that could even
substitute your own
experiences, as well.
DON DODGE: Amazing.
Well, Jennifer, thank you
for joining us today.
It's an amazing story.
And good luck to you
in the future.
JENNIFER REUTING: Well, thank
you for having me.
DON DODGE: Thanks.